Edward Snowden has proved himself to be
one of the or if not the most
influential whistleblower of our
generation hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
reason TV and today we're talking with
Trevor Timm he is the executive director
of the freedom of the press foundation
which is one of the groups that is
pushing for a pardon for Edward Snowden
right as the new movie by Oliver Stone
about edward sun comes out so Trevor
thanks for talking to us thanks for
having me you're pushing for a pardon
for Edward Snowden why are you doing
that and why now well you know I think
that Edward Snowden has proved himself
to be one of the or if not the most
influential whistleblower of our
generation you know we look back at the
three years since he came forward the
amount of change that has happened with
the US surveillance system the fact that
courts ruled it unconstitutional
directly related to his disclosures the
fact that Congress passed first
intelligence reform since the 1970s he
has had an enormous impact on how
Americans why would the president that
he you know kind of unmask why would he
ever pardon him well you know I think
that President Obama right now is he's
winding down his presidency is probably
looking at his legacy and one of the
most disappointing aspects of his
presidency has been his treatment of
whistleblowers and the fact that they've
prosecuted more leakers in history than
any other administration and you know he
himself has said that this debate that
Snowden sparked has made the country
stronger and you know it's certainly an
outside chance that he's going to get
pardon but I think it's something that
did Obama can and will seriously
consider what do you say to people who
say look Snowden's a traitor you know
what how could you pardon him well far
from being a traitor I think that he has
shown himself to be a whistleblower and
a patriot you know enshrined in our
Constitution is the fourth amendment
that you know makes illegal searches and
seizures that don't have probable cause
law enforcement didn't go to a judge to
get a warrant and with the mass
surveillance program that Snowden
revealed where you know the US was
collecting every single phone record of
every single American
whether they were guilty or innocent you
know that's just not how we operate in
this country and Snowden really exposed
that the government was was the one that
was violating the Constitution and and I
think we should be thankful for it do
you think have his revelations and the
changes in programs that have been made
have they weaken national security and
if they have is that the price we pay
for actually not just living or
believing in a free society but actually
insisting on a free society well I think
there's two aspects to that question one
you know the NSA had to come out and
basically admit that their mass
surveillance program there from their
phone collection program with every
single phone call in their database of
every single American never stopped any
terrorist attacks beyond that I think we
do recognize that we don't give the
police or the federal government full
authority to barge into our house
whenever they want or to read our email
and that if they were to do that yes
they might solve more crimes but we lose
a lot of our freedom and the rights as
Americans and so you know when edward
stone is sticking up for these rights
it's not just about you know do we stop
an attack or stop a crime from being
committed it's about you know how we
treat each other as Americans and how we
want to live in dignity does the Snowden
movie help your case in terms of
treating Edward Snowden as a patriot and
do you think it will help in terms of
generating interest in a part yeah I
think the movie is definitely going to
help with a lot of people who may not
have heard of the story before you know
that i'm partial to citizen for the
documentary that laura poitras made the
won the academy award that actually
followed the real-life story you know
obviously this film is a dramatization
but it tells a powerful story about
number one that the NSA was operating
this surveillance system in complete
secrecy and outside the law but number
two that the person that exposed it
edward snowden really had a good
intentions behind what he was doing he
would carefully thought about it and he
ultimately did the right thing by coming
forward to journalists do you think that
media portrayal of Snowden have
changed over time and are they getting
more fair less fair more bizarre yeah I
think once now that Snowden has kind of
been in the public consciousness for
three three and a half years now the
people have gotten to know him and a lot
of people who may have initially been
suspicious are realizing that you know
he had the best intentions when he did
this that this is he revealed something
that was very important that a lot of
people care about or maybe didn't even
realize that they cared about at the
time but now have come to the
realization that the privacy online is
very important and so I you know I've
been heartened to see the reaction so
far to the pardon campaigns been only
been going for a day but the fact that
there has been such public strong public
support i think is a good sign both
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump the
likely one of them is going to be the
next president Gary Johnson the
Libertarian candidate has said that he
considers Snowden a hero he would pardon
him leaving that aside who is the best
president to be elected for Edward
Snowden and more broadly more
importantly for questions about state
surveillance and transparency you know I
think that's a hard question to answer
because the candidates are all over the
place when it comes to surveillance you
know Donald Trump has talked about how
Snowden as a traitor and Hillary Clinton
has criticized them in the past but then
they both in other cases talked about
how there shouldn't be surveillance of
Americans going on without suspicion so
you know it's I don't know if it's
necessarily a 1 choice or the other when
we're talking specifically about Snowden
I think a pardon from from either of
them is quite a long shot what about
transparency is as a broader issue
because that's the one thing and even
Obama you know it seems the one thing
governments won't say is you know what
now that we live in a new world we're
actually going to behave differently
because we're going to get caught you
know would do either of these candidates
seem particularly good on the issue of
transparency well Donald Trump in
particular has been unbelievably awful
when it comes to press freedom for
example you know kicking reporters out
of their rallies telling me that he
wants to sue them but I don't think
either of the candidates
necessarily been beacons of transparency
you know the Clinton campaign to it has
been a lot of their scandals have been
caused by the fact that they stonewalled
and avoided the Freedom of Information
Act for four or five years and they may
not be in those position the position
there are now if they just complied with
transparency so do you think I mean in
the end maybe this is a way of talking
about it that it's we can never rely on
an individual person in government
especially the president certainly be
transparent or not and it's really going
to come from the demands of the governed
oh I think that's absolutely the
ultimate lesson that we've learned from
the Obama administration I mean you know
back when he was campaigning a lot of
transparency advocates were overjoyed
because he kept talking about this issue
a lot that he was going to be the most
transparent administration in history
and a lot of those issues he's done a
complete 180 and there's been a lot of
disappointed and dejected people in the
transparency community because of that
and so that's why it's it's extra
amazing to see people like edward snow
snowden coming forward you know kind of
forcing transparency where the
government kind of let down on their
promises well we will leave it there we
have been talking with Trevor Timm he is
the executive director of the freedom of
the press foundation part of a wide
alliance of people pushing for a pardon
for Edward Snowden Trevor thanks for
talking to reason thanks a lot